wenn jemand aus syrien kommt und hier
kommt wann es auffällig dass er sich die
brüste machen lassen kann
[Musik]
jetzt ist es ja so dass hier auf dem
messegelände in halle 26.000 flüchtlinge
untergebracht sind haben sie davon schon
gehört ja jetzt sagt wie die venus sagt
ja das ist super die sonne auch ruhig
mal vorbeikommen und sich das hier alles
an das sagen sie alle
und wie gesagt eigentlich möchte nicht
mit den tauschen die können ruhig noch
reinkommen ja jemand von der deutschen
kultur die ja irgendwie 27
die wir mitgebracht haben die sind nicht
von ruhmöller also haben wir ja was
können sie denn hier empfehlen was was
sollte man sich mal im i
zb die dildos auch kassetten oder so das
sind sachen die brücke liegt bei 6 sehr
helfen können
auch der sus das ist sehr wichtig man
muss das ist das auch ein
technologischer fortschritt denen der
westen gegenüber den den arabischen
staaten hat jedenfalls das ist falls das
nicht für voll zu nehmen
da kann man überhaupt nicht da die
berichten tiere haben wir haben durch
das was sie hier tragen ist das eine
landestypische tracht ja haupt der venus
jahren anzuschauen was ist das tolle
daran was kann so ein super das neue
jeden kommt von ihnen lernen kann von
wem das man einfach egal wo man herkommt
ist zu was bringen kann wenn man einfach
nur in diesen willensstärke und ist so
lieben habe die sachen disziplin hat
also da ist fleiß angesagt auch eine
gewisse professionalität man muss sich
selbst disziplinieren wenn man das
wirklich vollkommen selbstständig macht
also deutsche tugenden so gesehen
das ist also also ein
hochtechnologisches produkt aus amerika
aus dem silicon valley wahrscheinlich ja
nicht schlecht das kann diesen
flüchtlingen natürlich nicht leicht
aber der hat die möglichkeit hier auf
dem wellness messe in berlin islamisten
zu testen
okay das ist ja auch schon mal was also
irgendwie also im geschmack davon zu
bekommen was hochtechnologie im westen
bedeutet diese möglichkeit habt ihr hier
in dem man sich einfach in fingerlingen
und dann kann man so in seinem büro in
basel mit
das sind so ihre ihre kassenschlager
wenn man so sagen darf stühle speziell
und die fixe stelle produzieren sie
überhaupt pro jahr
das kommt es sich unterschiede in welche
länder liefern sie ihre stühle
ausschließlich in deutschland
wie heißt ihr fix stuhl unternehmen ssm
möbelbau sie als wirtschaftskrimi aus
dem hochschulbereich haben sie angst um
die deutsche wirtschaft nein absoluten
wenn jemand auch syrien kommt und hier
kommt vanessa fällig dass er sich die
brüste machen lassen kann
das was jeder mensch auf der welt für
sich entscheiden also brustvergrößerung
sind kein thema von religion hautfarbe
oder herkunft ja seine errungenschaften
demokratie ich bin für demokratie
problematik also sagen sie ihr
flüchtlinge rein raus rein raus rein
raus
ja das ist meine meinung ganz einfach
also wenn wir hier krieg haben oder uns
die probleme haben dann würden wir auch
gucken wo wir hinkommen und ansonsten es
meiner meinung wir haben eine sonne die
uns während wir trinken alle dasselbe
wasser und aus ihren arsch und als mein
arsch kommt dieselbe scheiße ist alles
gleich
das wirklich schwierigste werden was
neben als gerta die flüchtlinge werde es
wird schwieriger dann haben sie dafür
ihren fiction bereich auch gewisse
ängste dass es der wirtschaft nein habe
ich nicht in die ganze welt sagt wir
werden es schaffen
ich denke ja auch in frick stunde jeder
mitmachen kriegen muss sind besetzt wenn
man alle sie kriegt er wollte seine
schönen tag noch
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße